okay let me explain what's happening
right now we are actually at my house
we're in the basement of my house where
it's nice and quiet and it's Sona and I
and we had to tape some hats to to go
out and then I realized hey we're here
without our producer Matt Gourley so
this is our chance to dish on that
Gourley yeah oh he's not here
mm-hmm now don't get me wrong I love
girls coral that's why I call them girls
some of your nicknames what they're not
great girls geo URL Z Z okay it's corals
anyway he's not here so this is our
chance to talk about him mm-hmm dish sip
a little tea is that what the kids say
oh my god they say I don't know honestly
I've heard my daughter say it is it sip
a little tea you know what isn't it
spill the tea it's just bill the tea
well that's cuz you're dishing you're
dishing some hot Goss if you've got
something to add he doesn't have a
microphone no but he can you can just
lean in and say what does it play yeah I
think it's like or you say something and
you say like and that's the tea and
that's the ADI the tea is the Goss I
like saying let's brew the tea
oh let's brew the tea or let's let the
tea steep those aren't good let's let
the tea steep then we'll use some sort
of mesh to keep all little detritus out
of the cup and then we'll pour the tea
into the cup and enjoy the T hence
gossip do you like my way of saying it
well it's a process doesn't it take so
long can't you just say spill the tea
not the lines that's not what the way I
like to say it okay I'm sorry I just
brew the tea let it steep so the
nutrients and flavors from within the
leaf can become part of the broth then
strain aforementioned tea extracting
with mesh all detritus and then sip the
tea as it goes from warm to you you know
you're laughing and then you're always
putting a microphone away denying me of
the one thing I real
which is laughter you need it so badly
yes I do you're like a drug addict that
and that's the dress oh I was gonna say
like Tinker Bell but I remember you made
that analogy in the documentary you shot
ten years ago or you're like Tinker Bell
like you need applause or else you die
yeah yeah without laughter and applause
I die I'm sorry I moved the micro
someone's not laughing at me then I
don't exist well not only did you I'm
laughing but you needed to make sure
people knew I was laughing so if I
haven't made someone laugh within a
24-hour period it means I never did
exist all my past history is erased it's
a weird thing it's sort of like what's
that movie with Leonardo DiCaprio where
buildings fold into themselves the
revenant yeah yeah the revenue
remembering the revenant has skyscrapers
fold in on themselves yeah okay so
anyway inception be nice to me or Alize
not here okay let's talk okay our chance
this ability on girls girls yeah let's
brew remove detritus drinks at tea and
then spill said tea if there's any
leftover after we drink it
now listen I love the guy and he does an
amazing job he's like considered a god
in the podcast world I know and he does
look you can tell were in my house
because someone's ringing the bell who
is it it's probably Cora Lee so he
probably got into his vintage Saab in
anyway but he's not here and I just want
to say I do love the guy he's a maestro
yeah do you think that it's wrong that
we're talking about him when he's not
here to snow for himself no no no that's
the best time to talk about people when
behind their back yes yes
I grew up Irish Catholic as you all know
uh-huh and I grew up in a family where
you never confronted anybody at all you
just don't what you do is you wait till
they're out of the room don't you think
that that's wrong yeah that you should
talk to someone
yes directly oh it's terribly wrong okay
okay it's I mean there are a lot of
things that are wrong that we keep doing
right right I still eat pizza I'm not
supposed to eat pizza even to sell
pizzas amazing yeah no it's terrible
when it's wrong but this is the best
time to talk about Gourley because he
can't stand up for himself because when
people defend themselves it's just a
waste of time it's it's a time it means
that when someone says wait a minute you
just said that I'd like to defend myself
that's all time wasted it will right so
in your perfect world yeah you just go
after someone they don't stick up for
themselves they can't they're not there
[Laughter]